well thanks
uh thanks michael i'm super happy to be
here excited to be able to
share this work with you i'm going to be
talking about
my work building uh charitables and
thinking and talking and thinking about
designing technology for both
accessibility and engagement um so i
play as michael said i'm an
assistant professor in the hci um and
director of my
lab which uh called the actual lab
so just to start out to give some
context to this because i think a lot of
people have different definitions
for what accessibility means and what
engagement might mean so
choose your own definition but here is
how i think about these things
um my research like i said is focused on
accessibility so thinking about people
with diverse abilities
thinking about people with disabilities
and how they interact with technologies
how technology can better support and
break down barriers that
um either society has presented or
different technologies have
um uh created for them in terms of
interacting with
uh technology so my goal in this case is
more on the kind of functional side of
being able to do the things that we
would like to do
while interacting with technology on the
engagement side
i think of engagement as kind of the
traditional experience of interacting
with
technology interacting with experiences
and participating
in society in the activities that we
would like to participate in
and being engaged and having a positive
experience in those
situations so we want to think about
as we think about this in terms of a
research question um this
is probably a very common question that
you might find for accessibility
research so how can we design
devices and interfaces that better
support people with diverse abilities
um so i've been my generally my research
on charitable computing has been focused
around this question
related to how we use technology and
information technology and communication
technologies to support
wheelchair users for charitables so i'll
start
kind of as general as possible we think
of smartphones and mobile devices
you know we think of these devices as
being ubiquitous and providing this
means of interacting
connecting with people around us um the
capabilities of these devices change
every day and the things that we're able
to do
leveraging this functionality you know
continues to grow
on the side of wearable technologies
with this growing popularity of
of the technologies and the growing
availability of these
devices the impressive capabilities that
we i've leveraged with mobile computing
become even more convenient
you know to the point of very it is
literally right there on your body
um where one area where this
unprecedented access to technology
has the profound potential to impact
people's lives
is for accessibility so thinking about
how we consider
considering people with disabilities who
may have maybe dealing with other issues
that
technology can alleviate some of these
barriers but the technologies themselves
are far from perfect
you know not everyone is using the same
kinds of devices
nor are they interacting with those
devices in the same ways right
so in this in just this image there's
four images captured from one of my
studies
um showing different hand poses of
someone interacting with a touch
sensitive surface
um for an interactive surface so you
just have people with these different
kinds of
hand poses different kinds of fists uh
postures interacting to perform
particular gestures all of these folks
are performing the same kind of gesture
they're all performing a swipe on this
surface but you can see there's a
variety in how they might do that
furthermore we sometimes fail to
consider the other
devices or other assistive devices that
people might be using
while interacting with these uh with
these technologies like wheelchairs so
wheelchairs in particular we can think
of them as both creating
and alleviating challenges of
interacting with the computing device on
the one hand
the wheelchair is a mobility device
primarily but it can also limit a
person's ability to reach devices or to
traverse certain terrain or fit through
tight spaces when they're trying to move
around so you think of a kind of a whole
body situation versus an individual
device
on the other hand in terms of
alleviating some of the challenges
created a wheelchair
also has spaces to carry these devices
or store these devices
being able to carry and store multiple
computing devices or hide wires
without actually burdening the user as
we've seen with some early innovations
and wearable technologies
so what is a charitable so i mentioned
the word a few times so when
my research with terrible explores the
design of devices that leverage those
affordances of wheelchairs mostly the
positive ones
to support the needs of the actual user
of that wheelchair
so charitables are designed they're
devices they're designed to fit the
wheelchair's form factor
while maintaining its shape and
considering the abilities and
preferences of the user
so to give you an overview of some of
the research that we do
um in the lab and some of the things i'm
going to talk about in this talk
um the research we do span the number of
different areas relating to
a range of different abilities and
different activities so things from
designing interactive devices for
wheelchairs so the interaction
capabilities
thinking about wearables and athletics
social media access
thinking about how we can actually
facilitate co-design
navigation and spatial awareness and
also a newer area of ar and vr
access in this talk i'm going to focus
mainly on my work with charitables
so thinking talking through our initial
work in terms of thinking about how to
leverage the wheelchair
in design thinking about kind of the
first charitable that we built
the just rest which was a flexible input
device for power wheelchair users
and then talking about more of the work
uh getting into charitables for athletes
and some of the more current work what
i've been doing with wearables and spoke
sense and then i'll finish up with some
of the current and new directions
that we're taking in the lab and for the
research
we'll start with uh how we've
conceptualized design
thinking about leveraging the wheelchair
and design so i like to think of this as
participatory ideation and design
to get to the goals i'll preface this
with kind of the problem space
of motor impairment so thinking about
motor impairments and how
they can affect multiple parts of the
body so in addition to
using a wheelchair because of some
ambulatory ability where you might have
difficulty or an improvement to the legs
they may also have difficulty or an
impairment to
the head neck arms and hands and so
sometimes these devices or the devices
that
these impairments or the devices that
people are using can present prevent
present these challenges for users with
upper body
mobility impairments and the use of the
wheelchair as i mentioned can sometimes
exacerbate
these existing challenges and i'll give
you a couple of examples as we move
forward
again we can go back to that kind of
original question of how to design
devices and interfaces that better
support people with diverse abilities so
how do we support people using
wheelchairs and these devices together
so this initial study so in general my
research involves understanding
technology and people how the current
technology is working
developing solutions if an existing
solution can't be adapted or modified to
meet that need
and then evaluating those solutions in
this case the more the emphasis
has been on was on the design side of
how we should approach design
how should the users how do the users
actually approach this challenge and how
can we
involve uh the our target population
in the process of actually coming up
with these solutions and so in this
first study our goal was to understand
existing challenges with technology and
mobile devices
and ideate on what ideal desirable
solutions might be
that address the needs um that these
users have in relation to that
so we started with individual design
interviews with individual users
in their home along with design sessions
uh focused on
meeting their individual needs or
overcoming specific challenges that they
identified during our interview process
we then moved to focus groups with
clinicians to gain a broader perspective
on what might be useful
from those initial interviews for a
broader group of users so rather than
focus on an individual solution we
thought
about a broad range of input and output
technologies and techniques
and then we went back to the users again
to do configuration and design sessions
with those more generalized
solutions or generalized techniques
so to give you a sense of how what we
found during this study
so i'll give you a story about kyle
which is a pseudonym
to protect the identity of our
participants but kyle is someone who had
a spinal cord injury at a young age
he has suffered from paralysis below the
neck he's able to move his head and his
left shoulder
i mean he uses a head array or a set of
buttons that are mounted around
the head rest of his wheelchair to
actually control it drive it around and
control various functions
he was also very fortunate to have uh an
entire smart home
his his home was renovated completely to
become a state of the art smart home
actually on an extreme makeover home
edition
he's actually fortunate to have his
entire home renovated so
state-of-the-art uh controls for
different uh devices in his in his house
environmental controls doors he has a
really state-of-the-art
rehabilitation facility with temperature
controls and a pool
an elevator all these kinds of different
things and he controls all of that all
of his smart home features
using this tablet so one of the biggest
things that we talked about or two of
the things that we talked about
in the interview as his biggest
challenges were the positioning of the
tablet and being able to control it
and the mounting dimensions so for
positioning maybe this
image here of kyle actually using a
mouth stick with a with a stylus
attached to interact with his smartphone
in a similar way the tablet would be
actually mounted to the chair
using a metal arm and so it would
position the tablet so that he can reach
it with this
touch this touchscreen mouth stick right
after they renovated his home and did
all these interesting
interesting modifications and updates
the last thing they did did was mount
the tablet to his wheelchair
and so what this what the challenge was
that he encountered was he now has all
these controls that are accessible
through this tablet
which all you have to do is attach to
his chair but the mounting point on the
chair sits about four inches three or
four inches
to the right of his wheelbase and so it
actually extends the dimension of the
chair by about three to four inches when
the doors were designed
to fit the chair through just and allow
just enough clearance for the chair to
get through and maybe to turn a little
bit
so we actually can't when the tablet is
attached to that mounting arm
he actually can't fit through the doors
that he opens with the tablet
so he actually has to have someone come
in to remove the tablet and reattach it
when he goes like if he
wants to leave his bedroom he actually
has someone to either open the door and
then attach the tablet once he's outside
of the room
or to remove and replace it once he's
already through
and so what he wanted to be able to do
um to partially just to alleviate that
situation was to have
other controls that he could access on
his own so a switch control that he
wanted because he has some residual
motion that he can actually lift his
left shoulder
could he use a switch or a button that
was attached near his elbow
to control different devices or at least
to have that kind of input
in addition to the head array and also
just the real goal for him was to have
suitable
mounting for his display for his tablet
so that it didn't actually change
uh the dimensions of his chair he can
still access all the functions and
features that he had
that he'd grown to like and so one of
some of the things that i'll
i'll get into these um firms a little
bit later but this is demonstrating
three
concepts of charitables with this idea
of always available interfaces
which is common to wearable technologies
where you have
access to this device at all times
whenever you need it but also tailoring
to the specific abilities of the user
which is another common accessibility
approach or combining those two and then
adding in that this
idea of maintaining the silhouette or
the shape of the user
and their wheelchair together so
maintaining their body shape in these
uh ways as this kind of illustration
indicates
so i mentioned we went from the kind of
individualized interviews and design
sessions where we thought about those
individual solutions
to working with clinicians and
wheelchair users in a clinical setting
to get the perspective of people who
work with spinal cord injury patients
uh on the order owner of magnitude of
tens to fifteens to hundreds
of patients and work through a lot of
these issues in physical therapy and
occupational therapy
and so we spent four four days doing a
series of focus groups
with these clinicians and some and a few
wheelchair users
to ideate on what a solution might be
for a phone dialer a game controller
in the first case we focused on these
specific applications and then from kind
of examining the results of that
we moved into a more general space of
focusing on how people can input
information into
a system and then how can people
interact through
different kinds of innovative outputs
that we conducted either on four
consecutive days with
a series of people in and out after we
came
out of those focus groups we took those
results into individual design sessions
focused around the different inputs and
output techniques that
arose from that study and we asked
individual users to once again think
about
how they would configure an ideal
solution for them to make their
wheelchairs interactive
so if we started off by asking to
identify reachable areas on their
wheelchairs using a diagram similar to
this one
they could identify which areas they
could physically reach to interact with
some kind of input or some kind of
output
we ask them to then configure the inputs
and outputs that they would like
in those different locations describe
the functionality that they would
provide
and then rank their preferences for
different inputs and output techniques
or related to their configuration
and so the result of those uh focus
groups interviews and sections
was this kind of rank ordered list of
input and output types and the ways that
they might be
um attached or configured on the chair
and so from the input side
wheelchair integrated and wearable
inputs were the most popular removable
interfaces which are where the most
common at the time
moved to the number three position and
then gesture based interfaces
which we our definition for gesture
based interfaces with more in-air free
gestures so
actually being able to gesture in free
space open space rather than on a touch
screen or surface
and then on the output side head mounted
displays which were the most novel thing
at the time
the google glass had just been announced
and released it was one of
chosen for both the novelty and the
potential of having a very private
um display that only you could see but
interact with in a different way
and then add on screens of the more
traditional method and projected
interfaces
fell to third because there were only
three options there um the projected
interfaces presented a lot of potential
but at the same time a lot of privacy
implications that people just weren't
interested in dealing with they didn't
want to have their
text messages displayed on a wall next
to them or
onto another surface that anyone else
could walk by and use
um and so there was the overall high
level take away one of the takeaways
from that study were these this set of
five principles
which i used to guide designing
technologies and solutions for
wheelchair users
that leverage uh the wheelchair and so
the first one is
building on this idea of always
available so availability um you know
device should be always on or always
available at the very least
they should maintain the silhouette of
the user and their wheelchair
the devices should be tailored to
individual abilities
we should be considering strongly the
familiarity to known devices and systems
which is another kind of usability
principle we think about learnability
whereas we carry over the positive
effects of prior use of devices
but also we should understand kind of
the negative implications that devices
have had in the past
so for a lot of the technologies that
people had used they had
negative experiences with touch screens
or negative experiences with
gesture-based interfaces which
kind of limited their willingness to
attempt their willingness to try
new interaction techniques um because of
their past experiences with them so
in order to you know introduce these we
need to understand the relationship that
people currently have with those devices
and then finally robustness to different
environments and conditions of use so
um one thing i think we can all agree on
is that most of us you know
at least pre-pandemic do not spend all
of our lives in the same room we're
sitting in the same chair
um and so in this same context most
wheelchair users despite using the same
wheelchair
for most of their mobility needs will be
traveling and traversing multiple
different environments different weather
conditions different homes things like
that
and so the biggest enemy to any
electronic device right now i think we
can also agree
is water and so if it rains and you're
out in your fancy electronic wheelchair
with all your devices they need to be
able to handle that
but what did we do with that so we took
those principles and we wanted to
instantiate them in some way
and really to build you know what is the
first charitable look like
um so we took those kind of high
priority ranked preferences for inputs
and outputs
and came up with the just rest which is
a terrible for integrated control
so some of you may recognize this chair
or a chair that is similar to this is
that
the captain's chair from the starship
enterprise i believe this one is from
voyager
i could be wrong someone who's a bigger
star trek fan can please correct me
um but the point is if you've ever
watched the show
um one of the things that you'll notice
or that you'll notice now is that
anybody who sits in this chair
automatically becomes the captain and
the power of running the starship
enterprise
and leading the show leading the crew is
now given to them
just by sitting in this chair and so
this idea of
the captain in command of the ship and
captain of all the functionalities
being attached and being centered on
this one seat
is kind of what drove kind of the idea
of what charitables could be it also
happens to have integrated controls in
the exact locations where
wheelchair users also specified as
wanting to have those and this can
reconfigurable to
meet the needs of the particular captain
who is running the ship which controls
you one at your fingertips versus
farther away from you
i'll go back to this image of you know
what to give you kind of an idea of what
we're designing for what are we trying
to accommodate with this
as far as disabilities and accessibility
needs go we wanted to make sure that the
people
people are using this device which would
show and may show a lot of variation in
the way that they move
as well as the hand positions that they
might be using to interact with this
surface
and so in each of these images if we
start at the top left you can see this
person with an open
palm very loose very loose kind of uh
orientation of the fingers and as i
mentioned they're all performing the
same gesture as swipe the swipe from the
back of that touch pad to the front
and so for that person they're doing it
with that one finger and sliding forward
with their hands staying open the whole
time
on the top right you have kind of a
loosely clenched fist where they're
doing it more with their knuckles
person in the bottom right with a very
tightly clenched fish where they're
doing it more with kind of the bottom of
that
fist and then the person in the bottom
left where their hand is actually
contracted due to other lack of
rehabilitation and so they're actually
in a much more awkward position to try
to press down on the surface using the
top of their finger
but our device needs to be able to uh
work
in a similar way or in the same way for
all of these folks with these different
hand positions and poses
until the just rest fsr which is the
longer name or force sensitive resistor
is a pressure sensitive input device
rather than being capacitive
for touch and gesture input on the
wheelchair armrest so
ideal location integrated controls
so the idea was to enable users to
perform familiar gestures
but actually using the surfaces of their
wheelchair which they're already
accustomed to
rather than having to have a set of
switch controls which you would
need to mount multiple or having their
smartphone device out at all times
um so what this allowed us to do was to
support multiple interactions in a
single area
making it possible to replace you know
two or more switches that would take up
the same amount of space with a single
input surface also what this allows us
to do is not to explicitly need to
detect
individual fingers and instead rely on
the pressure being applied to the
surface
which allows the users to perform the
gestures with different parts of their
hand or even using a different kind of
tool
in addition to common touch screen
gestures that you might think of when we
think of touch gestures like tap swipes
and drags slides and things like that or
pinch or multi-touch
single touch gestures we also came up
with a set of five special gestures
specific to the armrest because this is
a form factor that
we really want to leverage and get the
most out of and so
we came up with these five special
gestures the first one being the squeeze
gesture
where if something a common action you
probably do with your arm rest of your
chair if you have one
you might squeeze the end of the armrest
and we can use that as a deliberate
input to the system
to control some functionality the second
one which is also one of my favorites
is the lift gesture which if you've ever
you know paid attention to the word at
the armrest not an arm raised
you actually rest your arms on the
surface for the majority of the time and
deliberately lift your arms off as an
action so
we can detect that and use that as an
input to the system as well does this
what does this mean when you lift
the punch gesture which is by far the
favorite of participants
something that you would like to do but
cannot do usually with your very
expensive smartphone
is to be able to apply a direct and
solid force against this armrest and
actually be able to measure that force
and understand that it was a punch or
very swift
swift motion the roll gesture in the
rock gesture
the roll being rolling your hand from
one side of the armrest to the other and
the rock being able to do that
alternating from inside and out
so we followed a similar approach to the
previous study
where we both involved both individual
wheelchair users and clinicians to gain
both an individualized perspective
and a broader perspective for multiple
patients or multiple users
when we evaluated these we conducted two
evaluations one where we specifically
uh explored um the fsr version
of the just rest where it's a just a
pressure sensitive armrest-based
interface
but we also wanted to understand whether
just by having the
the inputs in the right location whether
that was enough
to alleviate some of the issues so it's
always great when you come up with a new
solution
and that solution is definitely the best
but also we want to understand if just
placing the
the touch screen of the smartphone
closer to your fingertips where you need
it
and having that be integrated would also
be something that's suitable so we
wanted to really unders
understand that um so we tested each of
these devices and asked participants to
rate and describe
you know how difficult it was to perform
each of the touch screen gestures as
well as our special gestures
and then rank their preferred interfaces
out of four so they ranked out of these
four which ones were their favorite
um luckily for us thankfully for us
happily for us
uh the jeff the fsr version of it
actually did end up being the top ranked
um device but in terms of ease of use
all four of these devices made it
significantly easier for them to perform
these different kinds of gestures
than actually having to use their
smartphone or other device um the
reasons why
they were suggest why it was suggested
that this was their preferred device for
both wheelchair users and clinicians
um because of it was because of the
flexibility that that input offered them
in terms of being able to interact with
multiple parts of the hand
or using a tool while maintaining that
similarity to the touch screen in terms
of familiar gestures that they might
perform
on this middle image i want to draw your
attention to just for a second
is one of the things that our clinicians
that our occupational therapist did
instinctively
once i once we brought this device in
it's just to say one of the things that
we commonly do in the clinic when we're
working with a patient especially
someone who might have
a contraction of the hand or something
we want to be able to support their hand
properly so we'll often build up
some support on top of their existing
armrests using foam or clay
or some other tool and so if we are
doing that and you have this interactive
armrest surface
how is that going to work with our foam
and so they went and grabbed a block of
foam
and tried to all of the different
gestures and for you know for
demonstration purposes they all you know
they all worked so they were able to
perform the swipes the taps the presses
all through this
dense foam and so the density of the
foam would obviously impact that
but the general idea the flexibility to
be still be able to do that um
was maintained
so i want to kind of cycle through so
this has been kind of a discussion of
interaction technologies and charitables
so i wanted to briefly touch on what
comes after the just rest and what
is kind of the ongoing work in this
space and so the
big space for us right now is the
interaction and smart wheelchair so when
we think of
smart i have smart in quotes so you can
think of smart being autonomous
or smart being well connected and so
some of the things we want to do is
also examine more emerging interaction
techniques and how those
can translate or be applied to the
wheelchair how those can be applied to
chairs in general
beyond wheelchairs but being able to to
facilitate more
expressive interaction for people using
wheelchairs so being able to take
advantage of the latest enforce space
touch interfaces proximity-based
interactions what kinds of things can we
support this way through an integrated
means and i have a special
interest in dual purpose sensing so
being able to use
the same kinds of sensors the same type
of sensor same interactions for both
controlling interfaces interacting with
the environment but also to understand
more about what the users are doing and
their state whether it be for health
or wellness purposes or just for
monitoring and understanding what's
going on
and then i also mentioned about the ar
and vr accessibility
space that we're also aiming to extend
into
as we think about how the fine-grained
motions that are now possible to perform
especially using the latest
vr technologies a lot of them rely on
these hand controllers which are able to
detect the precise
positions of your fingers and are
allowing you to perform more
fine-grained motions
so what does that look like for someone
with a motor impairment who may
not be able to perform those specific
motions but still
can benefit from interacting in a vr
space
so for this next part of the talk i want
to shift the focus from
for more interactive technologies and
specifically how people with motor
impairments might be interacting with
devices
to thinking about what kinds of
charitables or wearables would be good
for
athletes and so this is work i'll talk
about wearables
and then talk about a system called
spoke sense
um so this the question kind of driving
this work was more
how can we design more inclusive
activity monitors for people with
differing abilities so there's still a
theme here
but we're thinking specifically about
activity monitors given the prevalence
and popularity of
fitness and activity uh trackers at the
time
so there's you know we have all these
companies be investing hundreds of
millions
into this fitness tracking and fitness
and activity monitoring space
um but we were seeing especially back
when the study was conducted this really
low adoption of these technologies among
people with disabilities
and so there's there were two schools of
thought on this whether it was because
of the affordability of the devices how
new
they were or whether there were
accessibility barriers that specifically
created challenges for people
who might benefit the most from these
kinds of technologies
so we our approach to this was we
started with looking at you know what
wearables were out uh what wearables
were available on the consumer side to
understand
um you know what were features of these
devices what functionalities did they
provide
um who different users what was your
intention
components etc we had conversations with
experts about the design of wearable
technologies in general
and about specific devices they worked
on we conducted semi-structured
interviews with athletes and coaches
um i'll get into observations and talk
about the national wheelchair basketball
tournament how that fits into
this line of work and then development
and testing of
actual devices which i mean by which i
mean smoke sense
so basically this is the result of our
early explorations into the space of
wearables for fitness most of the
devices that were
available at the time were some kind
they looked or worked very similar to
the apple watch that you see here most
of them had were wrist worn
form factor they had some kind of a
screen or at least a light
and they have the roughly the same kinds
of motion sensors
attached to them so they were able to do
the kind of basic motion tracking
and step counting
early on we conducted a bunch of these
studies and identified
a lot of different challenges that
people might have faced with wearable
technology designs
um especially with respect to uh
wearables
uh especially as we consider the
differences between different
bodies right so the human body is really
an extraordinary thing it's
extraordinarily adaptable to change
uh whether these changes occur early in
life or later in life our bodies are
really
able to adapt to changes caused by
traumatic injuries or disabilities
but these really these things can really
change our body shapes and our
physiology
so what uh what and how we're able to
adapt is really profound
thus making these uh different options a
challenge so the first one that we saw
was just in terms of body location and
sensing so
if you remember the foot pod uh the
little device that you might attach to
your shoe which would give you feedback
on your steps
and your gait your running speed heel
strike and all that kind of information
i would like my encouragement on these
kind of crude examples
but the first example is what if you
don't have a foot to attach the shoe to
then you can't put the foot pod on the
shoe um
which essentially removes that as an
option for step counting and activity
monitoring
um you might say that the next option is
physiological where you can
adapt new sensing types to understand
different elements of your body and your
exertion
um and analyzing one promising approach
would be sweat sensing so actually
analyzing the content of your sweat
apparently when you
exercise a lot you release certain
enzymes in your sweat which can be
measured
and then can give you feedback on how
much exertion you're experiencing
one of the interesting facts about
spinal cord injury is a
condition called hypohydrosis which is
the inability to sweat
below your injury level so if someone
has a very high level injury say a c5
are up here in the neck region below
that injury level they may not
have a reduced ability or even inability
to sweat which makes temperature
regulation very difficult
in terms of sweat fencing if you're
wearing the wrist worn sweat sensing
device
there if your diminished ability to
sweat we can't get a
very good signal from your sweat and
thus making that technique
ineffective at least in the body
location presented
despite these very um kind of crude
examples
the biggest um barrier that we saw for
wearable technology adoption was
actually just misperception of the
devices
and misperception of what they could do
so the first this quote from this
wheelchair rugby player
um i really love to use um these devices
they track steps and i do not take steps
so if i'm supposed to take ten thousand
steps a day i don't take any steps in a
day i use my chair i move around
the second one from a hand cyclist
mother of three who is also
an elementary school teacher so i can
imagine this person is never
sitting still never not moving i'm
sitting yes but i'm constantly rolling
around
i'm always interested to know not steps
but how much i'm actually moving around
i'm never a mobile this picture is not
of the actual person this is a picture
of tatiana mcfadden who is a
olympic a paralympic um wheelchair racer
um but you get the point this the people
are moving around they're never
you know sitting they're never sedentary
really they're not really actually like
sitting still
um so what's revealed about this is not
only that the words and perceptions of
the devices
are different but in some cases the
actual activities that we're interested
in monitoring
can also be different which led us to
ask you know what would appropriate
solutions in this space do
what do they look what would they look
like and how would they best be used
and so i have a couple of reasons for
why we chose to go with sports there's
another
a number of different activities we
could have gone with could have gone
with everyday activities we cooked on
with everyday
motion um training but in general
one of the big reasons why we went after
sports is if you think about modern day
sports especially mainstream sports
they're all driven by metrics whether
it's digital metrics or not
um they're competitive the engagement in
the physical activity
is well motivated so it's not something
that we have to deal with the
confounding variable of
this person is active on tuesdays and
wednesdays or fridays
we know that if they're playing the
sport they're going to be active at
least while they're playing the sport
and they're interested in numbers
because that is what drives the sport
baseball essentially is just statistics
i don't know if anybody actually plays
anymore they think they swing the bat
and then they count
similarly with all professional sports
that you'll see
if you dig far enough so i started to
i decided to start with wheelchair
basketball as an example wheelchair
sport
because of my personal connections with
basketball but also the opportunity
to get engaged with the professional
organization the national wheelchair
basketball
association which runs one of the
largest adaptive sports events in the
country
bringing together about a thousand
wheelchair athletes for a weekend which
rivals march madness in terms of content
and competition so you think march
madness is
spread out over the month of march the
national wheelchair basketball
tournament is all of that in a weekend
it's about 88 games on
friday 80 more games on saturday until
you have three
champions in the adult division three
champions of the junior divisions
woodrow basketball in general for some
background
is based on traditional basketball where
people are standing up and running
around
but adapted for use using a wheelchair
so some of the rules are changed
and they're using specialized athletic
wheelchairs one of the other really
interesting
facts about wheelchair basketball is
that it uses the functional
classification system which assigns each
player
a functional a number score for their
functional ability to perform
motions required for basketball so
someone with a very high level
injury or high level severity of
impairment may end up on the 1.0 side of
that scale where someone who has very
limited impact to their mobility of
their
motions maybe a 4.5
and so the way that this plays into
competition is that you can't have more
than 15 points on the court at any given
time
so you have to have a mixture of people
with different functional abilities
playing on the same team in different
positions so it gives you a sense of
kind of equitable competition
so what we did in this space was uh we
worked to develop spoke sense and this
uh liam here was gracious enough to
allow me to use his image
and to pose holding up uh our device as
our
official spokesperson for spokes sense
um at the tournament
um so we conducted these kind of early
studies but over the course of three
years we got to
explore um the space of interac of the
space of this activity tracking and
solutions for wheelchair basketball
we did these early studies at the
national tournament where we did you
know a few interviews
and a large 76-person survey of athletes
and coaches
to ask them about their preferences and
ideas desires for
devices that they might use or desires
for metrics and information that a
wearable device may provide
and so in as a result of those
interviews and the survey
we came out with a set of the
information that people were interested
in some of the metrics so they were
really interested in movement speed
acceleration and distance
they're interested in the number of
pushes respiration and breathing
and heart rate information so things
related to kind of stamina and fatigue
management
number of pushes is something that was
available at the time via things like
the apple watch
but it's still understanding how that
movement how the speed and acceleration
actually played out was much more
important to them than knowing the
number of pushes you can imagine a sloth
push will make you go
maybe a couple of inches and a hard push
may make you go a couple of feet to
yards or even all the way down the court
i think it's also important to point out
for the purposes of the work we were
actually thinking
we actually expected that what would
come out of this would be another risk
worn wearable
that these players and things players
and coaches would be uh interested in
using but it turned out that the form
factor the device was much more
important
than we expected um they were very
interested in something that could
attach
to the chair which is good for
charitables
but um the reason for it was because the
devices themselves the wrist worn
devices were mostly be considered
um wouldn't be considered permissible in
competition because they would be
considered jewelry so they wouldn't
actually be able to allow be allowed to
wear them during the games when they
really want access to that data
they could use them in practice but not
in competition
so we set out to uh fast forward a bit
and
look at actually wheelchair truck
realtor trackers and monitors
which there have been some developments
but the majority of the available
trackers that people could use were more
data loggers which required post hoc
data analysis so you would have to
download the data after the activity and
then process it analyze it in order to
get any feedback and sometimes
in some cases you'd have to wait even
more over months of the data and then go
back and say
it's great that on saturday march 15th
you had this really great workout
it's probably irrelevant to you now but
now that you can see the data we can
probably do something with it for next
year
um so we were aiming to provide
real-time feedback
for them using our device and so this is
spokessense which is a prototype
wheelchair basketball prototype device
for wheelchair basketball to give
immediate feedback on motion metrics
like the ones i described
specifically speed distance tilt and
others related to moving around
specifically in the chair so i'm briefly
going to talk about the interface and
the study we conducted at the 2018
wheelchair basketball tournament so give
you a sense of the device it's a very
small
imu with a microcontroller a 90 degree
freedom imu to do
orientation and motion metrics from the
both wheels of the chair so one on each
wheel and we were giving the athletes
feedback on things like speed distance
peak speed acceleration deceleration
braking
the turn direction and orientation of
their chair
we also included a microphone on the
device in order to provide some
indication of environmental factors
environmental features and i'll go into
a little bit about what we did with that
but first i want to call your attention
to kind of the orientation change events
so
some of the things are obvious that you
might think of for orientation
understanding orientation of the chair
like if someone is tipped over
to and may have fallen out of the chair
it's important to know that or maybe an
important event of interest
and another important event what people
will also do is to actually tip or tilt
up onto one wheel to gain a height
advantage
and this is something that actually you
can train for um it's not
so not only were you detecting the kind
of obvious events where you tipped all
the way over but we can also detect
when you have tilted up onto one wheel
and actually be able to measure and give
feedback for that so i'm going to
let patrick anderson demonstrate this
for you
you know he actually takes the wheel off
of the chair while still balancing on
those two wheels
pushes it around and because he's a show
off catches it
and reattaches it before coming down
so just like you know what you're seeing
and
kind of this amusement i i will let you
know my my best average for being able
to do this was about a minute
um and not continuously so a minute over
the course of a day where
i maybe got up on the wheel a couple of
times um versus but being able to track
this as an elite skill
this can gain you that kind of
competitive advantage and we want to be
able to give feedback on those kind of
specific motions and specific activities
that they might be doing
um as i mentioned we also included a
microphone
on the device because you can imagine if
we're recording data about all these
motions and all these metrics
over the period of a game which lasts
about an hour you imagine that's a
pretty long data stream so how do you
know
actually what types of things might have
happened in there how do you know where
to look for something interesting
maybe if you're not looking at the video
or if you want to have some kind of easy
indicator or
a way to segment that data into usable
segments right so we actually used game
sounds and a project called ub acoustics
which uses
a small sample of recorded game sounds
combined with audio collected through
existing
sound libraries to train a model that we
use to detect the buzzer
dribbling the basketball and the
referee's whistle
and so we use that to just kind of drop
markers in the data of when something
interesting might have happened
or when a person so when somebody's
dribbling and doing these other motions
how fast are they while they're
dribbling versus how fast are they not
um how fast you know when when a buzzer
happens it's either a substitution or
the end of a quarter
do we else we texted this we had a kind
of an open demonstration
and a short interview um which we
conducted at the 28 2017-2018 tournament
um you can imagine that people uh
players and coaches do not actually come
to tournaments to be parts of research
studies
so we had to keep every all of our
interactions very brief
but despite that we were able to gain a
lot of really interesting
data and learn a lot about kind of the
benefits and potential benefits of
having this device which provides this
real-time feedback
um and so the kind of some of the
obvious things were for goal setting
gives you some the having this objective
data gives you something that's
immediate and very concrete
so you're able to set your goals based
on this kind of known performance data
um but the one that i want to call your
attention to which is something that we
often overlook
and it's casual comparisons between your
peers or between
yourself and elite athletes so i asked
you to compare yourself or pass myself
to compare with what lebron james is
able to do on a basketball court how
high does he jump
i can get that information really easily
and say that he jumps higher than me but
not for long
for these casual comparisons with these
elite athletes this data is just not
really available
to them whether it's because no one's
collected or just because it's harder to
collect
in the moment i mean so being able to
make these kind of casual comparisons
between your elite peers
was something that was really desirable
and something they saw as a potential
here
um in addition to that being able to
evaluate your intuition so when you're
an athlete and you're competing with
teams
you kind of have a sense of you know
what uh what another player is able to
do or whatever their team is able to do
but can you actually compare yourself to
other people in your position
or other players with your same
functional classification so you have
this idea so
as from this what the quote suggests as
for teams competing with each other
you already kind of know what to expect
from intuition but you can add some
objectivity to confirm
or refute those intuitions and see where
you actually are versus a team
or someone you have less experience
playing with
and finally one of my favorite um
experiences from the tournament was
actually this idea of facilitating
competition
um and so this this apparently humble
stretch of concrete once you add some
cones
and lines people immediately start to
just fly through this as kind of a
speedway
once we added the actual metrics on a
large display and people could see
when you have the sensors on how fast
you're going it became something to be
the best in the building and so this
gentleman here
came back to our booth i think about six
or seven times in different chairs at
different times of day
just to make sure that he was the best
and the fastest person in the building
compared to anyone else who tried um
using the chair and for a long time he
was the fastest in the building there
was one person who got faster than him
and clocked in around 12 and a half
miles per hour
in a wheelchair so pretty extraordinary
stuff
and pretty fun to actually be able to be
in that space
um also in terms of augmented review you
know we can augment the existing
practices that people have for
interacting with this data we see a lot
of potential for this
in terms of ongoing development that
we're working on so being able to
facilitate team management working in
other sports
um analysis for everyday activities and
actually using again the dual purpose
sensing where spokes sense right now is
more for understanding how you're moving
but can we then translate that to add
input to a system or an interactive
experience
as i mentioned in this space those
technology roles in adaptive sports is
one area where
we're looking to extend this work so
thinking about sensing and feedback
system in other sports so like
wheelchair tennis or
baseball rugby or even sled hockey
for the last few minutes i just kind of
want to tease a couple of the other
projects and new directions that i'm
going in
mostly in the interest of time
the first one is kind of on a thread of
work so the next actually i'm going to
mention about three projects relating to
social media
access so along with former phd student
cole gleason
um we started to do this kind of social
media accessibility exploration where we
looked at
twitter and thinking about how social
media content has
uh really grown and become increasingly
visual
and despite the prevalence of images on
that are available on this platform our
analysis in 2019 revealed that most of
the images 99.9 percent of the images on
twitter
actually had image descriptions so the
image descriptions are that are the
descriptions or alternative text
descriptions you can provide
to let someone with a vision impairment
know or a captioning program
just a description of the image if
they're unable to see it
and so the feature existed but very few
images actually had these descriptions
and so we were interested in exploring
ways to automatically add alternative
text to these images
either post talk through another tool or
ways that we can support
content writers when they're actually
producing these descriptions in the
in the tool twitter has since made very
uh
extraordinary leaps in terms of making
that a better experience and more
accessible experience
but another really fun project that
we've been able to do is kind of
looking at um different types of content
so within that
space of images on social media we
extended that
work that finding these different types
of images one really prevalent type
that's become
really important to our society and how
we communicate online is memes
we may not use these image these macro
memes as much as
we used to in the past but most of these
images are not fully described
so you may get a description of the text
you may get a descript a vague
description of the image
or you may just get the word image as an
actual description which doesn't really
communicate
the humor and the experience of why this
image was shared in the first place
i mean so what we were actually
interested what we did was we explored
alternative ways of presenting this
content from first identifying the type
of meme and providing
if we knew it said for these types of
memes they're repeating and the text may
change but the background image doesn't
so being able to convey the text and the
description
as well as to be able to convey the
audio involved
or convey through audio the humor and
the overall message
of these so for the for image c of the
philosoraptor meme
we had some very celestial background
music
and then it would read off the text in
the same kind of screen reader voice
if the opposite of pro is khan is the
opposite of progress congress
and so that you know having that
celestial background music to give you
the feel
mean recently we started exploring how
access manifests
on in videos and video search for people
with vision impairments how do they find
videos on youtube that are accessible
how do they experience access
what makes videos more or less
accessible and how do you actually
choose which videos you're going to
watch although this is um
i'm going to be presented at kai um in
the coming year
another quick teaser just because i
think we are just about out of time i
don't want to have time for some
questions
um this project is actually looking more
on the navigation side
orientation and mobility getting into
you know how people move through space
but i think we can all agree that we've
been seeing these really interesting
bumpy tiles at the edge of the curbs for
many many many many many years and they
haven't really changed much
what you may not have known is that they
all have actual very specific meanings
that they are
supposed to have or relatively specific
meanings to indicate certain types of
hazards or to guide people
in specific ways and if you don't know
what those meanings are you're like most
people and most of the people that we
talk to
um through our survey of people vision
impairments and non-visual navigators
most people don't know these meanings to
the point where even the orientation and
mobility instructors
advise people to not trust what you
think that
that indicator means and use other
factors so we're interested in
building um building and expanding the
space of interactivity around these
types of devices whether it means
adding multimodal feedback to
interaction with these in indoor spaces
or being able to communicate with other
devices around these ground surface
indicators or even able
be able to customize them in a more
efficient way such
that they become more beneficial to the
users are supposed to
benefit um and then finally um
interested and started to explore this
space of accessibility mobility and
transportation
relating to autonomous vehicles and
access within those vehicles as well as
the impact of autonomous delivery robots
and
micro mobility options on the curb
on accessibility of the curb so people
traversing
pedestrian space now also interacting
with these robots and autonomous systems
and so with that i want to acknowledge
my collaborators and funding support for
this work
and thank you all for listening and take
questions
thanks very much we have a few questions
that are already in the form
as a reminder to everyone if you would
like to ask a question
please um submit it to the link i just
sent out
uh panelists i'll um i'll ask a couple
on behalf of the students
and then uh feel free to jump in with
any questions you have
um one we have uh who did a reverse
image search
on on your uh captain's chair says it's
from the jj abrams films so right now we
know
um uh
says he found the tipping and tilting
wheelchair really amazing was curious
how you
implemented that so it was actually not
too complex so because we have a sensor
on both of the wheels we can tell the
relative position
or the relative orientation change of
both of those wheels
um using the uh using the magnetometer
and the orientation sensor
that are already built into the imu and
then we kind of we can average that and
actually set just a threshold of when we
know that you've tilted all the way over
versus we use kind of more of a trial
and error process to figure out the
right
orientation change and actually ends up
being relative versus
a exact measurement so at the moment
we're not
measuring whether you're 15 inches off
the ground or 16 we're measuring whether
you're tilted and balanced versus
whether you've completely tipped over
and now the orientation of the
wheelchair is completely
changed and so we then reset that
periodically so that we know
if you're moving and staying in one
plane we don't have to then obvi
like the sensors kind of move around so
we need to know whether it's relative to
your current position
wondering you know because
folks abilities are so diverse and
specific how you think
about the line between um
creating bespoke solutions and
generalizing your solutions for a larger
set of abilities
so how do you how do you balance those
two
that's a great question um one of the
at least with the charitables work
that's one of the goals of why we went
after
the wheelchair as a platform rather than
specifically targeting
uh certain types of disabilities or
certain types of uh
motor impairments or limitations because
one of the things the common factors
there is the actual platform the chair
that they're using
is very is going to be very similar and
have similar features
so the way that i typically approach
this is to find
something that does provide that common
ground
and what kinds of what really to kind of
tease out where the modifications are
most necessary versus where there is
more opportunity to have a generalized
portion of the solution
so it's kind of if we have a base
platform that is more common
we can then start to slightly adapt at
that level and then we get more much
more fine grained once
it's actually with the user and you can
then personalize your custom setup so
the gestures
that you might the specific gestures you
might use with the just rest
versus the actual uh just rest type
so in that sense does it make you know
when i think about the stakeholders for
these kinds of designs there's the end
user but it also seems like the
i'm sorry i forgot the term you used for
them the sort of occupational therapist
essentially becomes
a real critical part of of the design
process it seems like it definitely uh
it definitely influences it i think
um one of the goals that we have is to
really is to try to be
is to try to capture as much of that
knowledge uh much of that generalized
knowledge of the therapists the
clinicians who are working
to design solutions for multiple people
they're working with a range of folks
and so
when we did our focus groups and our
design work
we ask them to think as broadly as
possible the people that they're working
with so not try not to
kind of counter-intuitively try not to
think of a specific person when you're
designing the solution
and think of as many people as possible
what would be what could be useful for
them and so
you often end up with something like
well if i can't choose for this person
specifically and that person
there i'll either make the button bigger
or put the button in the right place
and so that was you know kind of the
approach there okay
thanks uh panelists this is a good
moment if you'd like to jump in
i had a question um you presented
five different um sort of things to keep
in mind when you're developing terribles
and i was wondering um i mean they sound
they all sound um like things that i can
imagine
not all designers pay attention to so i
wonder
if you can identify one of them as um
like the largest reason for abandonment
or like does one of them particularly
stand out in existing technologies
that's a very good question so with
those five um
i think for abandonment often times it
ends up being i think if you had to
choose one it's probably tailoring
right so it goes back to this idea of
bespoke solutions
if the if the device is either not
tailored or not tailorable
then it's really not going to a person's
not going to continue to use it
if there's any issues for the in terms
of what the second most
uh important one there would be that
always available or always on
and i say that because it is also a
little ambiguous as to what i mean by
always available you always available
gives you a range of options
if it's always available because it's
nearby and i can reach it that's that
counts as always available
but it doesn't necessarily need to be on
at all times but we think of like
devices you might carry your laptop and
your backpack does that make it always
available
as long as your backpack is available
and as long as you can reach it
but actually bringing those controls
into a space where that person can
literally always
reach it right another student question
is wondering
is wondering about your thoughts on sort
of the trajectory of
brain computer interfaces for this kind
of group um
do you view that as a short-term
solution long-term solution you think
it's not going to solve the situation at
all
i think i think brain computer
interfaces are one component of
of a of potential solutions in this
space so i
i try to shy away from kind of the one
solution will solve all the problems
um some in some cases so a lot of brain
computer interfaces depending on how
they're implemented they use different
signals not everyone can produce those
signals
um in the general population and so the
you you can't
always rely on that as a as an
advancement they're also quite invasive
and so if you're
some of them are very quite invasive the
really effective ones often involve
actually implanting something on the
surface of the brain and then that
enables you very precise control or
precise access to those signals
the further away from the actual surface
of the brain you get those
systems sometimes degrade um i think
that there's a lot of potential for that
and
if we can train especially for people
with very severe impairments where that
is the
that it really is the only option for
providing a range
of actions and functions i think it's
perfectly viable i don't
so i think there's definitely long-term
implications as we get better i think
it's definitely a viable solution and
we should always get better at
understanding the intent of actions as
well
patrick i'm interested in your lab's
um relationship with your users
um do you have people that you can
follow long term to see the trajectory
of
their use of potential solutions and
new areas for refinement or is it more
like
the basketball tournament where
you get a chance and then
yeah so ideally we have both
the pandemic has definitely slowed down
our current
existing relationships um but the
what our what our plan is is actually to
work so for the athletic spaces to
actually work and
to keep relationships with teams so we
can work with them over a long period of
time
it's really hard to understand whether
something's going to be useful from a
couple of practices and especially not
from a tournament
one tournament so we need to actually we
do need to actually work with folks over
time we have a few teams that are
interested in working with us
and so once we can work out all of the
pandemic related details
um hopefully we'll be able to do some
long-term deployments of that kind of
those kinds of technologies
we also are building up the
relationships so i'm kind of the more
medical side so thinking about the
interactive technologies and health
sensing being able to actually work in
a long-term way with those participants
i wouldn't say it's quite at the level
of being able to follow them
you know for you know months or years at
a time but
um we will should be able to get beyond
the tournament style
uh data collection i think those kinds
of opportunities are are much better for
a large number of people at one time
versus
um having to work individually with uh
folks
along over a shorter period
all right i'm noting that we're at time
so i'm going to be that that guy
and say thank you so much to patrick for
joining us
uh we wish you could have been in person
but we're thrilled that we got
to hear from you regardless and i know a
number of members of our community are
meeting with you throughout today so
thank you for
spending some time with us